are you quarantining properly in the
sense that
i get the feeling you know you're being
careful but then i see you going down to
chappelle's place
first thing i did when the covet went
down i got like my whole
family on this plan i get tested
probably every three weeks on my own and
flying private so one is it and
chappelle's got testing
there too but why is it so important to
go to chapels i mean you've done a
million stand-up gigs
is it that you're going crazy and i just
need to get up on stage part of it's
crazy
part of it is it's weird i've had this
crazy year
and me and davis got closer so i just
i'm just in love with dave
right and i mean you know how this [ __ ]
is i like being around comedians
chappelle's genius i made it a point i
realized
cosby and richard pryor did not get a
law
right that's right richard and eddie
didn't get along
so i made it a [ __ ] conscious effort
me and dave chappelle are gonna get
along
it takes an evolved individual to
realize
there's enough in the world for you and
there's enough in the world for richard
pryor
yeah i always say it never comes out of
my check
right you know yeah will smith got
20 million dollars like it didn't come
out of my check
right the thing i love with dave we get
on stage we did
if if you were at my last tour if you
were in a couple of cities
it was like a couple of shows that were
just me and dave on stage for like
two hours you know he would call up my
road manager i'm coming and we'd set up
for him
and literally him and i would come on
stage together
wow we just riff you know we get on one
topic and he does his version of it and
i do my version of it
and we tag on each other's lines it's
like
like jay-z and kanye when they're on
tour together standing there while the
other guy's killing could [ __ ] just
screw you up
no i don't know i'm just not at that
point right now where i'm just
i'm secure with my spot i feel like a
maid man you know what i mean yeah
right you're an older statesman now yeah
i'm made man
and i just love dave and i look at it
like
a basquiat warhol thing like we're just
collaborating and when we're on stage
together when he's funny i'm being funny
when i'm being funny he's being funny